so
hey you guys
it's sunday look at how [ __ ] bright
that light is over there i know last
night was [ __ ] something else
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh volume off
that's why you did that
no i absolutely did not just he just
blames me for everything i'm gonna turn
this [ __ ] open this [ __ ] up it says zero
sugar there's no sweetness at all and
it's just zero sugar
it's all well
it is
that's why they i i told you that's why
they call all this diet drink zero
nowadays because they thought that they
were that diet stuff sounded too
feminine it was too feminine and dudes
wouldn't buy it yeah he's like i'm not
on a diet
so they had to make all the cans like
black and red and they [ __ ] on a
regiment
not a diet big difference
uh yeah regimen that's what they should
call it
yeah i know it's hilarious that it's
like you can't call it a diet because
that's two girls well in the latin
language it's called a hijimi
a regime
regimen
danny rowling says if burt reynolds got
cremated then that would make him burnt
reynolds verto stop
is that quite a dad joke i'm not real
yeah that kind of sounds like a bad joke
so we've been on this kick of watching
these old burt reynolds movies and uh oh
damn
[ __ ] pookie's throwing throwing the
[ __ ] toys like she'll pick up a damn
mouse and throw it one hand and chase it
um
watching watching like uh these old 70s
movies although this one's 80s this
one's 80s though
but when we started watching burt
reynolds it was burt reynolds back in
the 70s yeah and um
most of the time you know when you're
talking about like white lightning or
gator which is like that's part one part
two is gator and smoking a bandit and uh
uh for a cannonball run i don't think so
but he's in that but smoking about it
these were
these were movies that came out of
studios that were like
by southerners for southerners about the
south and just southern mentalities
they they were meant to be sold
in the southern regions in the movie
theaters there they didn't give a [ __ ]
whether or not
they sold to say like california or the
north the east you know they didn't care
because
you could recoup your you could recoup
all your expenses just in on memphis
sales alone because there's a pretty big
market
and uh this one was malone and i don't
know if this particular movie was
uh was oriented towards the south it
didn't quite feel like it
this one is a much more like general
action thriller it's actually based on a
novel
it's it's pretty good uh it's uh about
about a guy who's
kind of like uh he had a long history in
special operations he started in vietnam
and then he started working for
kind of clandestine type organizations
they show his record he's you know he
did some [ __ ] and [ __ ] laos and
yeah he's like a cia assassin
yeah he's like a contractor for him yeah
and uh worked in chile
probably you know
did some stuff for uh pinochet and stuff
but uh the movie starts where he's
supposed to be uh taking out this target
and he just sees the dude do this
through this rifle scope and he's like
nah i want to do it i quit yeah he just
kind of quit
and he kind of goes on to run he's got a
badass car it's kind of like from bullet
you know it's a little mustang
and he kind of runs up into the damn
mountains
it looks like california but it's oregon
it's oregon yeah it's oregon looks like
sierra nevada
and his car breaks down he's got to wait
for parts and
uh kind of falls into this friendship
with the mechanic and the mechanic's
daughter
and the mechanic's daughters
she's in her late teens early 20s but
yeah uh the the i looked up because i
was like well how old is her character
supposed to be yeah uh 17 17. her
characters i don't i don't know how it
was cynthia gibb who was in a bunch of
[ __ ] she was like in a bunch of tv and
everything i recognized her uh she was
actually in fame i think that's where i
recognized her from the tv show and the
movie
um but she was in a [ __ ] ton of other
stuff also but yeah she's supposed to be
17. no romantic relationship really
breaks out a lot of physical terms but
she got she has this crush on him he
doesn't he likes her but i don't think
he ever does anything about it no um
because he's 50 something you know yeah
and uh i would think that he's brought
50 in this huh he's got to be i mean
this was 87 yeah when this came out so
wearing a hairpiece you know that's not
man that's not his hair you can't even
see any damn sky
it's so lush
he'll be in full daylight and it's just
black like the black hole
it's sucking in
[ __ ] light you know
uh but
i don't know i enjoyed the movie for a
free movie you can watch this on uh
amazon and i think i think it was free
on youtube and that where we saw it free
on youtube
um
i came but i thought that we saw it on
amazon prime but i could be wrong yeah
it was
not a perfect movie but pretty good it
had some good gun fights in it
with uh guns that were kind of exotic
back in the day a lot of little mini
oozies and [ __ ]
suppressed stuff
um
he had it he had a damn uh wieldy it
looked like a [ __ ] one no it's an
auto mag 44 auto mag he's got one of
those
she finds it under the bed she's [ __ ]
snoopy that girl [ __ ] goes through
his [ __ ] [ __ ] just going through all
this stuff that's what i mean it is like
their house but
by the same token if i was a guest in
somebody's house i wouldn't want them
like poking through my [ __ ] yeah not
like i have anything like that's all
that scandalous but
it's just
an exotic invasion of privacy type
situation going on there which we took
touched on this earlier when we were
talking about
um i think it says beverly hills cop
three where they had the water mag i
think it was uh was it three or two i
don't remember i don't remember but uh
no [ __ ] assassins don't [ __ ] go
for [ __ ] that's exotic nothing they want
they go for stuff that's real common 22
long rifle nine millimeter 38 special
depending on whatever time time frame
we're talking about but they always got
to pull out this [ __ ] exotic [ __ ]
gun you know what i mean only he would
have it well [ __ ] that's a fingerprint
right there
yeah but for a movie it's cooler the
movie is even though in real life it
wouldn't make it yeah in a movie it's
cool but in real life that's they want
the exactly the opposite they want
something that [ __ ] doesn't call any
attention something they can throw away
something with real um
conservative ammo demands something you
can get ammo anywhere and there's just a
[ __ ] ton of it so yeah which does like
if you think about it and even if you're
trying to get in the cracks and yeah
yeah you should look as you shouldn't
look all slick and sharp anything like
that you should just look like a regular
ash lubs and nobody would like yeah
yeah which that's just try to try to
look as generic as possible
yep just like which would seem to be
common sense some of the stuff that the
move one of the movies that kind of
called it a little bit was what is it
three days the condor
where dude shows up dressed like the
mailman because you wouldn't know you
wouldn't really suspect a mailman and
he's got a bag and in the bag he had a
[ __ ] mac 10 but it was suppressed but
he had a whole government agency behind
him you know what i mean he wasn't gonna
get caught even if he got caught they'd
get him out of it
um
but uh
yeah real exotic [ __ ] nah
nah
slasher friend says this movie stars the
late cliff robertson that's right he was
the bad guy yeah who was known by many
spider-man fans for playing ben parker
in the original sam raimi trilogy that's
right see we got people in the damn
audience that know these two things well
yeah because like i said help it out on
the show it's all crowd source
[Laughter]
crowd
though it is actually it was like much
better than i was expecting somebody
asked if it was canon no it's not it's
not canon no you can tell it's not canon
this one actually seemed the one thing
that was interesting though was that uh
there wasn't a lot of
bert's regular humor in it now i haven't
seen a lot of his other movies that came
out around this time the ones that did
um and rob just mentioned this i think
critics would uh argue his choice of
films began going downhill around this
time though i liked this one yeah this
was a good cast um yeah i kind of feel
like he was kind of i i think he was
kind of having some trouble because some
movies he had done prior to this um
hadn't really done all that well so he
was kind of
you know again going downhill a little
bit and also i was like reading the
wikipedia page about this movie and i
had totally forgotten this but there
were rumors in the 80s like right around
this time that he had aids do you
remember that yeah it was true no it
wasn't true yeah but i had totally
forgotten those rumors dick slinger
everybody knew that [ __ ] he bert had a
reputation for just [ __ ] well yeah
yeah which may have not have been
deserved you know i think it more had to
do with the roles that he was in i don't
know anything about him personally i
know that [ __ ] long he ran off with
all his money
he [ __ ] basically left him
[ __ ] with a bunch of bills i think he
lost everything but from lonnie i don't
know exactly what the detail was that
but yeah i don't remember that either i
remember it being robbed
i remember it being like all in the
tabloids and stuff but i didn't really
like follow the saga yeah so i don't
really so i'm sure that probably didn't
help either yeah that he was in all the
tabloids and [ __ ] yeah um and then rob
said i like the part and then this made
me laugh too he said i like the part
where he kicks the dude and his nuts the
brother says he may never be able to
have kids malone says that could be a
blessing yeah yeah that was like one of
the funniest lines of the movie
this does not have a funny burt reynolds
in it it's very serious no yeah it's
various areas it's a lot more like
something about a death wish series or
something with the
what was his name
charles bronson yeah feels like a
charles bronson movie it does a bit and
actually i think as far as i could
determine i don't think uh burt reynolds
was necessarily the first choice for
this i think um
christopher lambert uh they were
maybe wanted him or something like that
so they were this is like i said it was
based on a novel so it's like a way more
serious
type of story tammy says saw burton an
interview back in the day saying it was
his hair he paid plenty of money for it
well in this one well not only i mean
you can tell it's like a hairpiece
because
not just because of how lush and full it
is and nobody's real hair looks like
that nobody's here looks like but in hd
yeah
um when he turns around you can see that
it doesn't quite i mean it's it's a good
hairpiece i'm not saying that it is but
in hd it looks like a slightly different
shade and it's slightly shinier yeah
than the real hair yeah um because when
he turned around they showed him from
the back like in kind of a close-up i
was like oh look you can see kind of the
line where the
where the hair piece stops and the real
hair kind of slicked back a little bit
like a pompadour not quite as tall but
yeah
it's floofy no man's scalp looks like
that with that haircut not beyond the
age of like 20
no and even at 20
you'll see scalp you don't see any scalp
yeah it's just it looks like a solid
massive looks like you went in and spray
painted his damn scalp
yeah
it's just like a hair yeah it looks like
a hat
like a hair hat
like a tint
but yeah so but yeah this is like a
really serious story so like i said he's
a cia assassin he decides i don't want
to do this [ __ ] anymore and obviously if
you're a cia assassin the cia's like no
you can't just like [ __ ] quit or
whatever because he doesn't tell anybody
right he has kind of a thing because
lauren hutton is in this too yeah um
briefly like she's only in like two or
three scenes right but she's like toward
the beginning you can tell that they're
uh she's also a cia assassin yeah and
she's just kind of like you can't just
quit or whatever and you can tell
there's kind of sexual tension there
that they've yeah
that they've had like a romantic thing
before but he's just like [ __ ] it i'm
out and so he just kind of like takes
off and he's in his car he's in oregon i
think they shot this in canada but i
think it's supposed to be oregon close
enough yeah um and his car breaks down
and like i said he ends up at this like
in this tiny little remote mountain town
uh at this mechanics place the mechanic
is played by
scott wilson who
younger viewers will recognize as
herschel from the walking dead uh maybe
slightly older viewers like myself will
uh recognize as one of the killers from
in cold blood yeah
now the cia assassin thing i always like
to talk about this because cia does not
have assassins they basically don't do
it but what they do is they'll hire
criminals to do stuff for them yeah
those guys are disposable but they nev
there's no such thing like i'm gonna
join the cia and become and said no
well i think it doesn't work that way in
this one yeah it's left like
he's like a private contract he's a
contractor but he works for the cia yeah
like on a freelance basis yeah so they
just like pay him to be like hey why
don't you be in this country and or
maybe he's working for outfits that kind
of contract for him it's you know
usually they'll distance themselves you
usually don't need
to
to take somebody out usually that's not
what they're doing usually all they have
to do is just
write a bunch of bad stories about them
in the newspaper get dirt on them that's
mostly what they're doing fourth jar
down said burt's hair is radar invisible
in this movie
[Laughter]
it really is it's honestly it's kind of
like
it doesn't look bad though i mean it
does look like an expensive you can tell
it's a hairpiece but it does look like
an expensive one it doesn't look like a
really like cheap job yeah he doesn't
just he just doesn't look like a real
person he looks like an actor and actors
from this time look like that it's
stagey yeah it doesn't look bad yeah
just that's all it's just you know it
was like
like a girl big old implants you know
those aren't real she looks good though
four star you know but that's that's the
same deal you know what i mean be like
yeah that's that's a good enough that'd
be a good analogy you know most dudes
hair from this era is probably to this
day too i had to check you look you see
him in the movies that's touched up
that's not the way his hair really looks
yeah you know or you'd be like a rock
just or in me just shave it all off and
that's it yeah that's my hair it ain't
there yeah yeah that seems easier like i
said i kind of wish i could do that and
then just yeah just shave it all [ __ ] it
off well i guess what tea said i don't
think tees has any hair
she's wears wigs yeah i mean i've i've
considered it yeah a lot of black girls
do that looking our friend there does it
what's her name the girl who [ __ ]
works for disney crystal crystal yeah
crystal yeah this doesn't have any hair
uh yeah it's well it's just because it's
such a pain yeah like because my hair is
so thick and it's just you know having
to like [ __ ] pull it out of the
[ __ ] shower dream the problem would
not with a girl not having hair the ones
that look good without hair don't weigh
anything them a hundred pound girls
[ __ ] skinny skinny skinny
if you just take an old normal woman
[ __ ] shave her head she looks funny
looking
slasher fred brings up uh this movie
stars lauren hutton who played the main
antagonist in a very classic 80s vampire
movie which i've seen multiple times
called once bitten
the very young jump jim carrey yeah it's
like a horror comedy
um i actually saw it i think it's on 2b
for free i think it came out in 85 i
want to say and it was one of those ones
that they kind of showed on cable all
the time so i've probably seen it like
40 million times and i've had i have
like scenes of it memorized um we should
like we should review that one of these
days somebody said we should also do
sharky's machine next yeah because i
think doesn't do stroke race didn't bert
might have directed sharky's machine i
think he directed like some of the
movies he was in i think he did stick
which we haven't done yet and i'm pretty
sure he did sharky's machine i don't
think he did stroker easter see when i
was a kid coming up in the 80s
we were catching the the burt reynolds
movies we were catching would be like
cannonball run
yeah and like smokey and the bandit and
stroker ace or is it stoker ace i think
it's a stroker he was stroke race right
and i think that i think that was him
that wasn't that wasn't tom cruise was
it no i think that was i think that was
burt reynolds yeah and that was
towards the end
of his
action career he's it's
he's starting to go into comedy kind of
stuff
and
guys my generation weren't into
burt reynolds movies that was more like
stuff that my dad would be into
but it's kind of good to go back and see
these old things you can appreciate the
age they aged well
they don't make movies like these
anymore
especially with the
white lightning and gator they don't
make movies like that anymore
rob says tom do you think a person could
survive that same gunshot that malone
took to the gut see i don't remember i
kind of yeah like during the big fire
fight at the end like or toward the end
you remember he gets shot like pretty
much right in the gut and i'm looking at
that going to be like that must have
killed him i mean yeah that looked like
he got like right in his [ __ ] liver
or something like that and then remember
the cops who were kind of in on the on
the shenanigans like the corruption or
whatever they put him in the back of the
cop car and they said yeah we're going
to take you to the
hospital right and then
and then he's like driving really fast
and like you know like that trying to
like [ __ ] shift all his contents
around yeah and uh and [ __ ] like that so
yeah so the fact that he actually kind
of survives yeah do you remember what it
was he got shot with whether three seven
magnum or something uh
i can't i thought it was a shotgun but i
could be able to shot a gunshot that's
what i mean maybe not i could be
remembering it wrong no but um
but yeah but yeah he it he got shot bad
it looked like it got him like right in
the [ __ ] gut in general
movie gunshot
wounds are ridiculous the guy gets shot
and then he's running around even in the
arm
it's very rare that it's something to
the audience
like the more you run around like the
more blood will pump out of it because
your heart rate goes up when you're
running around sometimes it depends what
it is i mean uh i've seen videos of guys
that were down in afghanistan got shot
shot it was either in the arm of the leg
with an ak but it didn't hit bone
and he's walking around yeah he got shot
i got to go to the aid station and he
was all right but it didn't hit bone it
didn't hit an artery
and um
aka an ak round is a full metal jacket
round it's only 30 caliber
and depending on what velocity it is
when it hits you like if it's at a
distance it may have slowed down a
little bit some
it can make kind of a surgical wound
like an ice pick
because it because the way the soviets
had kind of worked that round out is
they wanted it to be more towards armor
penetration to penetrate through
the aluminum sides of a [ __ ] american
apc and just you know just
basic armor it can kind of go through it
so it's more about the price the the
primary
uh action
of a bullet is penetration not
fragmentation but penetration
it's better to penetrate and get in
there and get and hit something than to
have a fragment on the surface
even though fragmentation
does a lot of damage you just can't
depend on fragmentation
in a military situation you got guys
hiding behind trees and you're gonna
have to chew through trees and
people inside of buildings and you gotta
chew through walls you know given enough
time and enough ammunition you can just
chew through anything
especially if it's something big like 50
cal
so military's going to go to
something that's cheap and something
that penetrates
because you know [ __ ] man keeping a
whole army in action every day depending
on how much ammunition they're shooting
up and a lot of times they're shooting
up a lot
it costs a lot so you're trying to
reduce the cost of the round you don't
want any expensive
[ __ ] hollow points and lead you know
you try to
minimize the amount of lead because lead
is more expensive than say like certain
kinds of mild steels you know those are
more
commonly available it's not strategic
you don't want copper you know
we use real expensive [ __ ] but we pay
for it
the soviets use cheaper [ __ ] they just
give out more ammunition
so something like that yeah you can get
hit with it
and if it mis doesn't really hit
anything important you can you can walk
it off but you're not going to be
fighting if you if you hit given the
choice unless you're fighting for your
life you know
so i've seen some guys walk but what
they're showing in these movies is [ __ ]
like 37 magnum pistol rounds
between cops or guys that are agents or
something they're going to be carrying
[ __ ] jacketed hollow points probably
and [ __ ] you up yeah you got shot man
there's all kinds of stuff in there
kidneys
livers
guts
toxic shock sets in i mean it was like
yeah it might like perforate your
intestine or your intestinal wall or
something like that if you go up higher
there's lungs in there so you're going
to come up with things like sucking
chest wounds and [ __ ] where you got to
[ __ ]
you got to [ __ ] seal everything off
so a guy can get a breath you know he's
trying to breathe and suck it in through
the holes and
it's a complication and then there's
arteries running everywhere you don't
want to get shot anywhere
because everything on your body does
something yeah i would agree with that
everything on your body does something
you try not to get shot pro tip yeah
you get shot in the hand you know what i
mean and there's bones in there and it
blows the bones out the back the fingers
are [ __ ] going out in every [ __ ]
direction and then they're gonna have to
put that hand back together hopefully if
it's possible
and they may not be able to put that
hand back together depending on what it
was it hit you
you know five five six does crazy [ __ ]
especially up close you know they could
[ __ ] just fragment a [ __ ] hand
or you hit an arm and it [ __ ] just
the bone just explodes like a [ __ ]
bomb and it's [ __ ] hanging by [ __ ]
pieces of meat and [ __ ] it's nasty nasty
[ __ ]
especially with a bunch of guys up close
shooting at you shooting at one dude
it's just like
[ __ ] shreds them up you know there's
photographs out there you can see what
it looks like
and headshots [ __ ] man bullet goes in
pressurizes the head [ __ ] just turns
the brain up [ __ ] [ __ ] comes flying
out pink mist and [ __ ]
you can see it live time they got battle
footage out there gun camera footage
dudes being vaporized
uh according to rob i was right it was a
shotgun oh gut shot with a shout out
well see i even thought that in the
movie i'm just like yeah that he'd be
dead yeah something like double and then
especially after
him getting shot it's like even if it
didn't kill you outright
him getting jostled around in that
[ __ ] cop car like that i'm like yeah
he would be totally dead and then so it
wasn't just that it was just like a few
days later he was like walking around
fine yeah no and that and they even kind
of like said like because didn't lauren
hutton's character like savage i was
like i can't believe that you're like
you're that you're okay after that he's
just like well yeah i'm a [ __ ] badass
yeah that means he didn't say that but
that was kind of the implication i
didn't realize it was a shotgun i was
i'm yeah i thought it was uh oh i wanted
to give a shout out to oracle guess who
got her pathology report back everything
benign okay good hooray
yeah that's awesome
that's awesome yeah um
[ __ ] 12-gauge shotgun shells it
probably would have been using something
like double up buck which is like six or
seven 30 caliber pellets it's kind of
like getting shots six times with a nine
millimeter
all up close it churn and it's lead
lead pellets they're soft they [ __ ]
smear
there's no jacket there's no casing on
them no jackets
and then you know it's something like
number four buck it's even worse it's
like a bunch of [ __ ] 22 caliber
bullets hitting you all in one spot so i
get hit with a burst of a sub machine
gun
but it's all up close you can see
photographs what it looks like
especially if it's a close range now if
he was further out you know 25 meters
they spread out a little bit maybe only
one or two pellets will hit you
but if it was
probably from the movies they usually
show a guy getting shot close range
with shotguns and
i mean like punching your fist through
something it was pretty far away
the guy that shot him was fairly far
away but i mean the wound that they
showed i was just kind of like uh he
just got killed you know what i mean was
it one hole or was it multiple holes all
up close um i can't really i think it
was just one hole but like i said it was
like and it wasn't even like it didn't
even wing him it was just kind of like
right there you know what i mean i was
like pretty sure there's some important
uh organs there
that you kind of need to continue living
well if the pattern opened up and most
of the pellets hit him and only one hit
him maybe he could survive it but it
would have been a 30 caliber pellet
probably depending on what it was if it
was double off buck and it would have
mashed out
you know and it would have done damage
in there they'd have to get it out it
probably would have gone through them
yeah so maybe
it probably would have gone through and
come to think of it so basically i mean
what happened to this like i said he's a
cia assassin he quits he ends up just
randomly in this town because his car
breaks down and he ends up staying with
the mechanic played by scott wilson and
he stays in their house because he's
like hey we live out in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere and it's going to take a
few days for the parts for your car to
come in because it's like a transmission
problem
and so he lets him stay in the house and
then he kind of gets involved with
there's this shady
politician businessman type of dude and
he has like all these henchmen and he's
like buying up all these properties and
if you won't sell to him then he will
basically like [ __ ] your [ __ ] up like
burn it down or have you killed or
something like that and then it turns
out that he's some kind of like weird
like white nationalist like [ __ ]
terrorist cells or something and he has
like all these kind of like things so
there's so he kind of gets embroiled in
that like yeah without like uh it's just
like i said randomly and then
uh because he quit the cia
then they actually send lauren hutton to
come and kill him like she's supposed to
poison him yeah but she's like in love
with them and so she doesn't and then
she ends up getting killed
and then there's like just this big
[ __ ] fire fight where you know him
and like the remaining townspeople that
don't want to move like fight back
against the other dudes and so there's
like a big thing but um let's talk a
little bit too about because i think we
brought this up on one of the shows
is that the mechanic
has a daughter who is 17 names joe
and
she is all about that burt reynolds
action yeah she wants to jump on that d
so bad yeah um well she hasn't been
anywhere i she's been up in the damn
mountains by herself and i'm sitting
there watching it and i'm watching it
and i'm just like this isn't gonna go
the way i think it's gonna go is it
because i was like that girl is clearly
old enough to be his daughter by quite a
substantial margin yeah and i'm like i'm
gonna be really mad if this goes in like
some weird she's like you know what i
mean it doesn't but it does get a little
i don't i don't know it does get a
little weird but it's more like her
kind of like pursuing if she's like
fascinated by him i guess yeah um and so
she like creeps around in his room like
looking through his [ __ ] like he'll be
out on the porch like doing like smoking
or looking at the stars or whatever and
she'll come out there like in a robe
like to talk to him and stuff so she's
like
and he seems like kind of
i don't know it kind of seemed like it
was gonna go in that direction and i'm
kind of like ew but you know what i'm
but it does she's cute but he's just
knows he knows that she's doing yeah
cause that's the thing and then they do
kind of establish like that he had
something going with like lauren hutton
who obviously was a lot more
age-appropriate yeah um so there was
that but it was like i don't know i did
kind of like think that it was gonna go
like in a weird in a weird like
reynolds bang's a teenager type of thing
and i was just like
this is like really strange but yeah it
doesn't go that way yeah women worry
about that a lot well no i'm just saying
it's like i thought it was like creepy i
thought it was creepy and i was she
liked him she liked him uh but the thing
is is that he burt reynolds is burt
reynolds he was in good shape but he
wasn't in that good shape
he went in that good shape i don't think
yeah i mean i like like you said you
could kind of see it because you know
she was 17 she was from this tiny tiny
little town she's never been anywhere
she's never seen anything and this is
just like a fascinating like mysterious
dude
he doesn't say that he's a secret agent
but it like comes off that way he comes
off as like there's something like
really intriguing and mysterious about
him like at first i think she thinks
that he's a criminal yeah um which again
she's just kind of like oh crap yeah she
might have it yeah
she might like that too he had a badass
car and he had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] his stashes of hidden weapons up
underneath it that's pretty cool
i don't know if you could have stashed
that shotgun up underneath that car
and then
he didn't not had that mechanic notice
it though because it mechanic knows what
it what an undercarriage looks like well
maybe he did notice it and he said i'm
just to leave that there
that's all right i'm sure that's there
for a reason yeah
well because
the mechanic i mean they were kind of
they were both um you know they vietnam
veterans obviously they were doing
different [ __ ] but they were like both
over there so they kind of like bonded
over that yeah and
i and i liked that like scott wilson's
character his name's paul isn't it paul
barlow or bartow or something yeah
something like that and um
he was kind of like he didn't really ask
like burt reynolds like hey are you a
criminal or anything like that i don't
think
um he was just kind of like well you've
got your [ __ ] going and i'm just gonna
trust that you're like an okay dude
because you seem like an okay dude asked
him when he was over there and he
[ __ ] gave dates where he was over
there before the ward before the war
started so he's like that's a little
early isn't it and he's like no for what
i was doing yeah see but there was cia
was doing stuff down yeah a lot of
intelligence
agencies were doing stuff down there
before the war started so i kind of feel
like because they had bonded over that
he was just kind of like well i think
this is a good dude and i'm not going to
like probe too much into his
background he's a dangerous dude yeah
because he's like obviously i don't so
so maybe he did when he was working on
the car maybe he did see that gun over
there and he just said well i'm just
going to leave that there because that's
that's his [ __ ] and i'm just i'm not
asking any questions yeah um well you
couldn't tell it was good i knew his gun
when he was taking it out but then he
unwrapped it and everything it was a
shotgun
and he seemed like i remember correctly
scott wilson uh his character seemed
like pretty okay with
uh burt reynolds like hanging out with
his 17 year old daughter yeah and what
was weird is you know you don't have to
hot shotgun in the united states those
were illegal and if i remember correctly
it was a short braille shotgun you could
have those too especially if you had you
could get those licensed
it was just there for clandestine
purposes
that way he could get through security i
guess that'd be the only reason why
you'd ever have to hide it
yeah or yeah it's you always have one as
like a backup that people don't know
about you know what i mean if some if
you get like in a situation and there's
like undercovers yeah or somebody's just
kind of like you can't just have [ __ ]
like in your trunk or like in a really
obvious place right it was something to
sneak into a place with it yeah that's
what i'm saying so that's probably what
it was but yeah this is um i haven't
really heard much about this movie and
like i said we just kind of i think i
vaguely remember hearing the name of it
but i never really heard anybody talk
about it i remember the name but i never
saw it yeah i didn't either i don't
think and so it was just interesting
that we just kind of found it randomly
because we were like hey it's free and
burt reynolds is in it and we're kind of
on the burt reynolds kick at the moment
it was good it was i don't like a
high-end canon movie
yeah it does yeah it definitely didn't
have that cheesiness like you can tell
how cheap it was like like in the canon
one like like the charles bronson when
that we did the other day the
assassination where you could absolutely
tell it was dc but there's palm trees
yeah you know it was that one was so bad
it was good
that's true they were they made it out
of chin
but i was just rolling with it
yeah i was just rolling with that it was
still entertaining that was that was the
whole idea they were just trying to
entertain you yeah this one seemed a lot
more like i said serious a lot more like
a real movie decently budgeted yeah i
kind of felt like that canon one it
didn't really seem exactly like a rope
like obviously it seemed like a real
movie but like i said there was it had
like a very chintzy yeah feels here this
one i think was trying to be like bullet
the car was kind of like bullet there
were some chase scenes
they weren't as good as something out of
bullet it wasn't as dry as bullet um
but it was kind of imagine imagine if
you had some
cannon trying to do bullet but they had
money
reynolds actually
bert reynolds actually compared this to
like shane or first blood yeah somewhere
around there kind of yeah which yeah the
tonally it is kind of like that where
it's just somebody that like like a
badass like randomly ends up in this
town and kind of gets involved with yeah
this you know corruption and [ __ ] that's
going on he's coming like like first
blood yeah yeah he's like not so much
like rant like the second one like rambo
or anything but he's like like that of
course it's not showcasing physicality
stallone was in [ __ ] super good shape
for first blood
there was a lot of physical action where
he's out there just with a damn knife
you know [ __ ] freezing to death in
the win and the range there isn't stuff
like that it's more kind of like secret
agent stuff yeah he's he comes across
like burt reynolds i actually quite
liked him in this because he does come
across as like very stoic yeah and just
kind of like cool as a cucumber type of
thing like i love that scene in the
barber shop like where that guy comes in
like
he is gonna kill him right and then he's
just there with the newspaper over his
lap you know do you remember that scene
where he's like where are you where do
you say like kind of like saying that he
has a gun under there and it's like that
was a great [ __ ] scene i like that i
don't remember if he had one in there or
not um well he didn't he just had a well
he had his finger under it like that but
then like later after he turned the
tables on the guy then he'd actually did
that one somewhere else so he did end up
blowing that dude away yeah um but yeah
this had like a lot of a lot of
shootings a lot of explosions
um but yeah it was just like a really
good like sleazy ass villain yeah this
one i think i think repeat viewings it
might hold up i wouldn't mind seeing it
again later on
yeah it looks like it felt kind of like
a movie that could grow on you if you've
seen it a couple times
yeah like i said i really i actually
really uh
surprised myself with how much i enjoyed
this one yeah i just i just really liked
how cool bert reynolds was in it yeah i
enjoyed it i did it as well i just want
to know if i'd like it if i saw it again
if i'd like it better or less
sometimes repeat viewings really kind of
helps you establish whether or not you
actually if it
helps you to establish whether or not
the movie is actually good or if you
actually like it
yeah and you see it again you're like
hey you know no you know sometimes you
see the gig oh no that's cool that's
cool part you know you see things in it
you didn't see before
that's why i'm i'm actually like a big
advocate and like i said i like to have
uh you know quite a bit of time in
between but if i liked a movie the first
time or i thought it was like a good
idea but i didn't there was some stuff i
didn't get or whatever i usually like to
give it another chance like you know six
months a year down the road and see
because you pick up a lot more stuff
yeah the second time i watched zardoz
again yesterday was the day before was
yesterday the day before uh i think it
was yesterday and uh i liked it but of
course i didn't watch the intro of that
dude talking i [ __ ] skipped that with
his with his it's a lot better just
start that down the head shows up
zardoz has spoken
but i liked it better on repeat would
have seen it again i saw a lot more in
it um
but also
later on some of the technology the way
they're describing the technology is
kind of tedious because i try to
describe technologies like metaverses
and internets to an audience that has no
idea what that is which everybody knows
what that is yeah it gets kind of
so you're like all right we got it
but back then right and biotech
respawning people through biotechnology
and then downloading the consciousness
through this
into those bodies so you could come back
to life
they had to kinda be kinda
and they couldn't directly they didn't
have the vocabulary to describe it too
well
yeah
oracle says i can't believe christopher
lambert was under consideration for this
um
yeah it would have been a little weird
you know what have been weirder the
other actor they were considering was um
gerard depardieu which would have been
very strange
um i know he was in serious [ __ ] too but
i kind of felt like i don't know i felt
i feel like
in american movies he usually played
like comedic roles at least the stuff
that i saw him in i know that in french
movies he played more like serious stuff
but strong dogs talk about born losers
about a vietnam veteran versus bikers
i'd like to see that one i've never
heard that one wait a minute wait a
minute oh
yeah yeah i did see that one now where
they're fighting in that bar
now i'd have to see that again i'm
pretty sure i saw that i think i saw
that one it's not that old i think it's
from the 80s isn't it
it's not the 80s it's not that old
you know i was thinking when i was
thinking biker movies i'm always
thinking of the 60s yeah because there
weren't yeah there were all right yes
they did something on mystery science
theater like the hell cats right what
was that other one they did with the
side hackers yeah that was a good one
[Laughter]
chili peppers burned my gut but yeah
so yeah this is uh i think it's amazon
prime i can't remember if it's amazon
prime or if it's youtube but it's on one
of the streaming services
for free must have been amazon prime
because i don't remember watch seeing
any ads and if it was on youtube for
free then it would have ads
and i'm pretty sure we watched it
without ads so i think it was amazon
prime
so uh yeah so i don't know like we might
watch another
do you want to do another burp movie
yeah tomorrow or you know it's up to you
we can if you want yeah we'll find one
um
or we can go back to horror movies or we
can do whatever we could do both
but it just depends
uh but yeah so
you know
i guess uh you can watch i'm kind of
sleepy from last night although i didn't
get sue i just i had stuck with beer
last night um
just for whatever reason i don't know
every time i go to wills pub even though
because when we used to go to will's pub
a long time ago they didn't have a
liquor license all they had was beer and
wine
so
uh so i just got used to every time you
go to will's pub i would just you know
drink beer even though i'm not a big
beer person but so now i just associate
will's pub with beer so i just usually
get beer when i'm there but they have
hard liquor now though i got drunk and i
i uh informed the starry night that i
was a white hispanic and didn't buy it
elia's going good you're a white
hispanic what makes you wise
[Laughter]
portuguese manchester because you are
white
yeah
i think i missed that conversation
yeah they're like thank you for like
actual yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah from
actual
he had to straighten me out on that i
guess well yeah yeah you're not you're
not allowed you know you have to be a
white dude yeah i had to be a white guy
it was a good show last night though we
had a good yeah good job and uh the
opening band was good too they were
called laboratory yeah and uh yeah they
were also quite yeah a cute little chick
came out of damn grave and just looking
dance a little coffin that yeah
and she had glow-in-the-dark uh contact
yes that was like pretty cool they said
they had like black light yeah i got a
shirt from them yeah we got a shirt from
them we got a sorry night shirt and we
have a little boat
where's their cd it's right over there
all right we'll get that where is it
it's right over there on top of my phone
on top of the phone on top of the phone
right there this one yeah yeah go ahead
and plug that one yeah this is a new
yeah this is their their newest one yeah
we got it to 10 uh
i always buy i always buy cds from them
you know what i mean just so
just pop them into your damn xbox and
play him yeah that's what we do because
i got that the sound bar it's got good
quality on it
but uh
i just like to have physical product too
yeah you know yeah it's important in the
band yeah it's only 10 bucks
there you go yep and uh i was going to
say something else too about um
no i can't remember what it was
[ __ ] dude
uh yep just went right out of my head
all right i guess i am kind of sleepy
i'm almost kind of hungry too yes i can
make something i was going to make
something before and then you gotta be
show time
okay whatcha gonna make i don't know
probably uh some pork tenderloin or
something
we'll see i gotta get down here and see
what's available all right we're gonna
go down there and see what's uh what's
up
so yeah we might do another burt
reynolds movie for tomorrow so
uh have a good rest of your weekend
everybody
and uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
afternoon
bye